the whole world was looking for the next
I read I don't know if I can live up to
that I don't think Tony would have done
what he did if he didn't know that you
were gonna be here after he was gone we
have a job to do you're coming with can
you give that to MJ you do something
average to me happy
you got this
starke made you an Avenger the world
needs that
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have a brand new spider-man far from
home trailer to break down it does seem
like Sony is giving us a lot with these
trailers but they are doing a great job
at getting everybody hyped up for
spider-man far from home so there are a
couple of important scenes we have to
break down in this new TV spot but a
reminder to anyone who's new to my
channel when I hit 400,000 subscribers I
will be picking three winners and each
winner will get to choose one item from
the Marvel Legends series collection
I'll talk more about how to enter at the
end of this video so right away we have
some new dialogue and footage of Peter
talking about Tony Stark it's obvious on
so many levels that Peter is just
heartbroken and crushed on so many
different levels that Tony is now gone
he was a mentor to him a father figure
to him and really the only male role
model that he had in his life and now
that he's gone it's very evident that
everybody else expects him to step up
and be the new Iron Man to take the
place of Tony Stark we hear him say the
whole world is looking for the next Iron
Man I don't think I can live up to that
and you can notice that when he says
this he's practically crying so this is
most likely after he's already fought a
few of the elementals and failed so
everybody's kind of looking to Peter to
step up now happy is now this new father
figure to him and he's encouraging him
to be like Tony was and then you have
Nick Fury telling him that he's going to
help not asking him but telling him that
he's going to come with them to help and
we hear Nick Fury say stark made you an
Avenger the world needs that so again
just another person telling him that he
needs to step up this trailer really
seems to be about the emotional hardship
that Peters going to go through in the
film Peter is just trying to be a
teenager but so much is expected of him
now he's supposed to be the new Iron Man
so that's a lot of pressure and on top
of it
NJ now knows that Peter Parker is
spider-man we see here in this scene
Peter Parker hugging MJ in the
spider-man suit without the mask on so
probably not just MJ but a few people
are going to learn that Peter is
spider-man in spider-man far from home
if you look at his spider suit it's
really charred up so he most likely just
went up against the fire elemental and
again it looks like Peter is going to
have a really hard time fighting these
elementals until Mysterio shows up but
MJ finds out that Peter Parker is
spider-man and spider-man far from home
which is huge and kind of weird that
put it in the trailer but still and then
the last thing that I want to talk about
is the building that used to be the
Avengers tower now in the first
spider-man far from home trailer that
we've got this building was still in
construction it was still being built
but now it looks like it is completely
done so now obviously the big question
is what is this building who built it
now I know a lot of people want it to be
the Fantastic Four Tower but I'm going
with its Oscorp tower it's too early for
the Fantastic Four to be introduced into
the MCU Kevin Feige already said we're
probably not gonna see them for another
five years so this is most likely the
Oscorp tower setting up Norman Osborn
and the Green Goblin for the next
spider-man film we know he signed up for
three solo films so there's going to be
another one after spider-man far from
home so we probably won't see much of
this building or anybody in it
throughout the film but we might see
something about it in the post credits
scene setting up the Green Goblin
and that's it for my breakdown of this
new spider-man far from home TV spot let
me know what you think about it let me
know what you think about MJ discovering
that Peter is spider-man and let me know
if you think that the old Avengers Tower
is now going to be the Oscorp tower let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below and again at the 400,000
subscriber mark I will be picking not
one but three winners and each winner
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're a number